c'est étonnant non
petite une petite parenthèse
qui nous a servi les programmes de la
semaine dernière moi j'ai ici Télé 7
poches
là-bas voilà
télévision les programmes de la semaine
prochaine sont beaucoup plus
encourageants que ceux de la semaine
dernière d'abord demain matin 9h30 et
orthodoxie qui est une émission
formidable où on voit pas monsieur Ferré
ni monsieur Baumel ni monsieur Cannes
c'est la seule il y a même pas Travolta
dimanche après-midi il y a une mission
fantastique qui s'appelle incroyable
mais vrai ou le présentateur va montrer
un cheveu de 5 cm donc
c'est incroyable mais vrai
ensuite
lundi matin lundi matin il y a une très
bonne émission qui est sur TF1 qui
s'appelle les visiteurs du jour de
d'Anne Sinclair alors c'est le thème
justement est sur l'alternance Anne
Sinclair reçoit Daniel Gilbert
[Rires]
esse
vous pouvez compter sur nous c'est une
nouvelle émission de Pierre Bellemare là
une dame qui est demandé un chien
d'aveugle depuis 10 ans
si c'est vraiment intéressant mais alors
en lui téléphonait de la mairie pour lui
donner son chien aveugle mais comme elle
était sourde elle entendait pas
finalement grâce à Bellemare elle a un
berger allemand qui arrête pas de la
mort parce qu'elle est arabe mais enfin
ça peut être une bonne émission
oui lundi le journal de 20h le journal
de 20H lundi le journal de 20H lundi est
exceptionnel il y a une interview de
Madame Annie Grangier qui est présidente
de l'Association des femmes battues qui
viendra avec des photos d'Anne Sinclair
et Daniel Gilbert
vous aurez également lundi toujours sur
FR3 qui est une très bonne chaîne
une émission qui s'appelle décrochage
régional je sais pas si vous avez vu et
Rennes Nantes présente une émission qui
s'appelle et Cléo el diesum mène au
doudou doudou doudou pilou pouet pouet
c'est une bonne émission aussi toute la
semaine
mais bien sûr que c'est
mardi mardi sur Antenne 2 déchiffrer des
lettres Lafont Patrice Laffont va parler
de ses lectures préférées qui sont
consonnes voyelles voyelles voyelles en
salle les gens d'ici vous ne parliez
tout à l'heure des gens d'ici c'est une
émission formidable de gens qui n'ont
rien à dire et qu'ils disent avec
beaucoup d'émotions
mercredi mercredi le magazine de que
personne regarde c'est une heure assez
bâtarde qui est à 13h40
maizinodisep un métier pour demain
aujourd'hui rien repasser
est fracture avec un singe clair
je vais arriver au bout de la semaine
comme ça jeudi réponse à tout la
question est quand je pense à Fernande
que dois-je faire
jeudi encore sur Antenne 2 histoire d'un
bonheur à c'est un feuilleton qui est
moi qui nous tire les larmes qui
existent depuis un moment le 29e épisode
alice veut cacher une jeune juive chez
elle mais Hans appartient à la Gestapo
sémantine voilà ça c'est la question à
poser ça c'est les feuilletons qui
bougent jeudi encore télévision
régionale petront peut-on apprivoiser
une huître par le professeur Fournier
il y aura Philippe Labro qui va parler
de son livre Marcel Julian et surtout
Jean-Pierre Elkabbache
qui parle un peu de son livre qui
s'appelle taisez-vous La Broque
vendredi
il y aura les jeux de 20h avec Nicole
question qui jouera le mot est biroute
et puis samedi enfin pour finir droit de
réponse on termine droit de réponse de
Michel Polac qui s'obstine alors le
Michel polla qui s'obstine a refusé de
nous dire dès le lundi la liste des
invités qu'il reste le jeudi et le thème
de l'émission sera doit-on dresser la
liste des invités dès le lundi
[Musique]